uh good morning everybody and uh welcome
to this meeting of the traffic covered
19 public engagement board
which i think will be probably our final
meeting
um i don't have any apologies this
morning has anyone got any any apologies
to throw into the meeting please
apologies were received from george
devlin thank you george devlin
thank you for that
are they declarations of interest in
today's agenda items
i don't see anyone acknowledging can we
take the minutes of the last meeting
as read and a true and accurate record
thank you for that
so with no more uh do we'll go on to our
update um on
i suppose it's now is it to helen living
with covid
um we'll have that we have had the
government's uh
guidance that's been published
at a time when our infection rates are
on the up again
so perhaps you can probably tell us how
best to live with this and avoid
um actually coming into contact with
kovid thank you helen
thanks councillor freeman so um
if i go through our epi and then talk
through some key points as well for um
the meeting members uh after that so if
we look at our rates you are right
unfortunately we are seeing an increase
in our rates locally at the moment so we
have a rate of 530 per 100 000 which is
uh 1200 of our residents testing
positive in the week up to friday the
11th of march and this is an increase
from the previous week
um
we are the highest in greater manchester
um and we are higher than stockport
which is our that the borough with the
closest rates to us
um in terms of positivity so the
proportion of people who go for tests
and tests positive that's increased as
well so we have a rate of 20
of people who go for a test test
positive
um in terms of where we sit as i said
before we are trafford is the highest
borough followed by stockport berry and
salford
and we have seen an increase
a significant increase over the last
seven days in terms of our rates
um all our age groups have seen an
increase as well so it's not across one
particular group
um but our highest rates still remain in
our 30 to 44 year olds and our
understanding there is that may be where
we've got the lowest vaccination
coverage but also that there they will
be the group who are out working
socializing and potentially you've got
very young children as well so they've
got a mix of risk factors there
um in terms of across the borough where
we're seeing the highest rates um it's
kind of quite a mix across the west and
the south so davey hume east ward has
the highest rates at the moment followed
by bowdoin armstrong tinkly and
ultringham
so you can see that mix across there
and then um
what we would say is that our hospital
rates our ventilation beds and our
deaths are all remaining stable so that
that's reassuring anyhow at the moment
in terms of kind of um the wider picture
i think if we think about what's
happening in trafford at the moment i
have had conversations with oxa as was
public health england yesterday just to
have a look at what's going on and our
understanding is this is the impact the
change in policy this is this is us
starting to live with covid and we did
anticipate a drift up
when the policy changed but this you
know we just need to be mindful of
monitoring that drift at the moment and
understanding what that means so we're
working very very closely with oops or
colleagues in terms of the monitoring
that information
and yeah it's all down to change in
policy and changing behaviors which i'll
touch on at the end of my summary really
we are seeing increased outbreak
activities across our schools and our
care homes which uh kirsty and beanish
will talk us through um in a moment but
again just to uh just to assure members
of the board um that we do we we are
continuing with our outbreak response
for the next 12 months
anyone can get in touch with the covered
response team if they're a resident or
business or a member of a complex
setting from across trafford for advice
and support
around any coded
issues that they're experiencing
um or key messages
and obviously the other the other issue
is that testing will change so from the
30th of march free testing will end but
ben is on the corner can talk us through
what that what that looks like
in terms of living with covid um
i think we have to just be mindful that
it hasn't gone away um
we're maybe not getting the profile of
covid on the national reporting at the
moment and that is absolutely justified
by what we're seeing the horrific um
issues happening across europe at the
moment but i think as a resident group
and as councillors and as professionals
working across trafford we need to
reinforce the messages that covert
hasn't gone away um
that you know if you do have symptoms um
of covid then
don't go into work stay off work and
have a pcr test while the pcrs are still
available and that's really really
important and when testing isn't
available if you do
you know do feel poorly then still do do
not go into work for at least five days
really until you feel well again
and that's really important um
and just to say on that i did have
covered last week actually and it
started as a heavy cold and fatigue so
just thinking about the symptoms that
we're seeing
um to test while tests are still
available do you know lfd test if you're
going out and seeing anyone who's
vulnerable or going into crowded areas
and do go for pcr tests if you are
symptomatic
hand washing is still really important
and our community engagement teams are
doing lots of work out in our schools uh
to work with our younger kind of
residents in terms of hand washing and
awareness ventilation get your windows
open get your doors open it's not
today's a bit of a glum day isn't it but
you know where you can do get some air
flowing through
but absolutely our key message is
vaccination so if you haven't had your
booster or you haven't had your primary
or your second it's never too late um go
on to the national system to book for
your vaccination
and that's really really important
so it's a bit of a difficult picture for
us at the moment not difficult a
challenging picture for us at the moment
we are still working uh in terms of the
covered response and supporting our
residents and working with the national
and local teams as well
but we will
do want to assure the board that
everything is in place and we are
working um against guidance and
everything else with guidance sorry
as this is our potentially our last peb
i just wanted to um
thank particularly thank um the system
the nhs social care and the public
health team for all their amazing work
but i wanted to also thank our settings
so our care homes our
care providers have been absolutely
phenomenal throughout what you know we
look back on the last two years it's
really hard to believe that we've lived
through a pandemic of this kind so to
thank all our residents our businesses
and our settings for their support and
their help and for their engagement as
well but also to thank all residents i
think
trafford residents are
very good at following rules which is
brilliant uh you know our testing rates
have been really high we've had really
good engagement and we just really
wanted to thank residents for that and
finally to thank our counselors as well
for allowing
us
to share information with them and for
those for them to be our voices out in
the community to to let us know what's
happening out in the community but also
to take our messages out so i just
wanted to thank everybody there we will
continue to watch our rates very very
carefully and we'll provide updates um
or any any further you know changes and
anything that we see coming through
to
members of this group virtually for the
next few weeks and then look um at the
ongoing approach as well so thanks
cancer feeling
thank you helen and i would echo those
thanks i think that this has been a
particularly successful board we have a
question from uh council accordingly
uh thanks chair um and and thank you to
the chair and to helen and to eleanor
and everybody else as well
um whose grisha now thanks i think we've
come through it
reasonably well so far um
hospitalizations is what i was going i
know i keep not looking at them and they
they are going up but it's hard to
understand what's going on there are
they people who are otherwise ill
who happen to have coveted or are they
in hospital because of covid
um
and that that that's a difficult one but
the the rates are definitely going up
across the northwest
um
i do worry about the global view i worry
about china has
seen massive rates and um
we know what happens when you get mass
infection you also get
hybrid and um new variants and things
like that so i don't think it's gone
away um so
hospitalizations is one thing
and
readiness to return to sort of
a more um
a more serious um
regime if you like going back to that
regime if we need to
um that's my other question really
thank you council cordelie helen
so just on the um hospitalizations so
our analyst tom series working with
colleagues at mft to understand that
data um and so there's a number of
different scenarios people who
go into hospital and are swapped um and
have covered
um or people who are in hospital because
of the infection but also then people
who have a nose or comal um infection
which is one that's picked up in
hospital so there is a lot of work on
going at the moment around that
and working with our gm
colleagues so we will again as soon as
that data is available share that data
in terms of readiness to return to
restrictions obviously
we have to listen to
government advice but we work very
closely with uxa and um
and so we would be we are we have a
really good response team available for
the next 12 months that we can stand up
really quickly um i think that's one of
the things that makes me really proud is
that the team the way the team is
structured and the way the team can
mobilize and respond to
the ebb and flow of the waves that we've
seen over the last two years has been
phenomenal um and so so locally as well
we have that plan in place council
accordingly so
what we're just working on at the moment
is escalation through in terms of
decision making through the organization
but we've got no concerns about that as
well so just to reassure you that
everything is in place if we should need
to escalate again but obviously
i think the the the challenge is um that
aligning the trafford response to the
the national response which is something
we have to be very careful with in terms
of guidance but the other thing to say i
think gm
um trafford are brave when we need to
take a decision we do take a decision so
if we think about
the
testing on discharging to care homes in
the first wave and then the bringing
measures in to schools in october we
went before anyone else so this isn't
something that i think the board needs
to be concerned about we will
make the appropriate decisions um
if necessary but but on the whole we are
absolutely follow the national guidance
thank you
uh thank you well and that's really
reassuring i've got a question from mark
mark jarvis so it wasn't really a
question counselor it was a bit more
information about hospital rates so
the figures today
mft
which is um our major provider is that
we have there were 223 people admitted
um who have covered
in the last week which is up from 207
the previous week so locally the rates
are going up although the number of
people in intensive care have gone down
so the impact of vaccination means far
fewer people are ending up seriously ill
we've never had the split on those
figures we're we're using a a comparable
figure
um because that's always the figure
we've had the number of people in
hospital with covid whether that is the
cause or whether it's an incidental um
and you know but helen's already
explained the work
to break it down into those three
categories the cause of admission and
incidental or actually hospital acquired
is ongoing
because that's critical to our learning
for the future
thank you mark councillor new gross did
you have a question
it wasn't a question it was to echo
those thanks to all our officers all of
the staff that's worked on this i wanted
to raise the points that we had
trafford had gone ahead of national
guidance twice
very importantly i mean
i was one of those calling for it and
and
i was very glad we did
maybe uh part of research in the future
is to see what difference that made for
us locally but
my thanks to everyone for that it really
was a big big thing
thank you class of new glossian
councillor blackburn
thank you could i ask um those people
that are
currently in hospital
have they do we know if if a if they've
had kobe before
or if they haven't been vaccinated is um
do do we have that sort of data
so we will have in this analysis um i'm
not sure about the previous coveted
infection but we do have a data flow in
terms of reinfection but whether we can
link that through to the hospital data
may be more challenging but we will have
vaccination status as well and i think
this is really important piece of work
in terms of our inequalities as well to
understand
um who
results you know who ends up going into
hospital their vaccination status but
also
you know um the risk factors other risk
factors that result in hospital
admission as well so it will inform the
inequality's work going forward very
much
yeah and could you just ask one other
thing um
obviously those
people who unfortunately
have died
and
there's
you know there's dying with covid or
dying
because of covid
um
will will there be sort of any data
about that in the future or can that not
be
you know can that not sort of be divided
up
it can be divided up because um when
when you register a class you'd have
your primary course secondary course for
example and it'd be looking at that
level of data
my understanding is that works on going
at gm and obviously at national level as
well in terms of
um
the impact of covered on our death rates
we do report excess deaths as well so
that's another piece of work so what we
would expect to see in a population
compared to what we do see and the
causes of death and there's actually
it's quite interesting at the moment in
terms of the excess deaths it's not
what we're seeing is
higher death rates from our kind of
long-term conditions rather than covered
so it's thinking about how we can
support our population who are living
with long-term conditions to to
live safely with covid obviously but
also how we protect our population in
general from developing reducing their
risk from developing um the long-term
conditions so when i say long-term
conditions i'm talking about things like
diabetes
coronary heart disease for example which
all have you know increase your risk
significantly from the harm of covid i
don't know if mark wanted to come in
there around long-term condition
management mark and prevention of it's a
prevention bit for us it's absolutely
crucial i would say
mark
it's where the data gets more and more
complex isn't it because
there are
people dying of other conditions
but it is a consequence of covid
putting pressure on parts of the system
you know and the the coveted
restrictions making it more difficult
for
lots of healthcare environments to
deliver their services in the way
they've previously done and therefore
they're having it to adapt and also
the public's behavior of trying to keep
the pressure off the nhs and not bother
nhs systems in the early stages of the
pandemic will also have led to late
presentation of some problems that that
may result in earlier deaths so
you know the statistics and the
um complications of how much impact
covid has
is going to be really difficult to work
out but
fundamentally your
gps in trafford have tried hard to
maintain a level of service for all the
long-term conditions while the
government guidance was to to completely
stop and not do anything um
we didn't really want people sat there
twiddling their thumbs on the the brief
periods that there was a reduction in
demand um so we have tried to maintain
some of those services we're delivering
them differently
because we still want to maintain well
we still have the infection protection
and control measures in
healthcare settings so we don't have the
footfall in gp practices we previously
would have done so you know we are doing
far more telephone reviews we are only
seeing fake people face to face when we
need to but we've worked hard to try and
maintain
that long-term condition management to a
standard and we're picking up the
face-to-face bits that we haven't been
able to do
because you know it has been a
contributor to the increased death rates
um might be difficult to identify how
much it's contributed but you know we
recognize it has and we know we need to
pick up that work again um and get on
top of all of those you know and
we've as you'll read in the past press
um even if
gp and community services are
identifying these things when they refer
them into secondary care secondary care
have got the problems in delivering
those services
and you know today's
messages have been this is not just
financial this is the people
to deliver the services you could throw
money at the nhs now
with little impact because
we're now running short of the people to
deliver the services so
again there are complexities to
how
things are going to change going
forwards and what the
recovery times may end up being
can i just say finally um reciprocate
what everybody else has said
um everybody has not just gone the extra
mile you've gone the extra 100 miles and
you know health public health
social care everybody has done
as much as they possibly can to look
after us to keep us safe thank you thank
you
thank you for that councillor blackburn
i don't see any uh further questions at
all
uh so thank you helen for for the update
there and we'll move on to uh mass
testing with ben i hope you recovered
ben because she worked with us at the
last meeting and perhaps you can
probably explain how we're going to
continue to track
uh where we are when free testing ends
and also free access to lfd test cents
thank you very much ben thanks very much
and yes thank you i have just about
recovered i may start coughing a few
times jordan this but otherwise i'm well
thank you
um so first of all in terms of the
changes that are coming up that um helen
spoke about before
let's start off with pcr testing so
universal free pcr testing stops at the
end of this month um so that means that
the 30th of march is the final day for
local testing sites so the two that
we've got are pathington and trevor park
a regional testing site so that's the
ones at the etihad manchester airport
and any business usual mobile test unit
so again we've got one for five days a
week in stratford
as well as this universal free access to
actual flow test is also going to an end
at the end of the month
there will be some groups so that would
be the amino suppressed the we think
over 75s and health and social gas staff
that are still going to be able to
access lateral flow tests if they have
symptoms but we're still waiting for
guidance on exactly how that's going to
work
uh when it comes to outbreaks we still
have access to logic flow testing and
test units to use um if that happens in
key settings for the time being
so in terms of monitoring that i guess
like i say we're still going to have um
ongoing testing in some groups and i
suppose they will be our real indicators
um of of an increase um over the next
kind of few months um from when it comes
to advice so for the next two weeks i
suppose it's still crucial to remember
pcr tests are still available like flow
tests are still free
so and this will be the final time we
have to say this in this meeting if
you've got symptoms you can still get
that pcr test you can and before going
out and about you can still take a
lecture flow test you've got um they can
be ordered online they can be obtained
from traffic libraries um and yes and as
the chair alluded to at the start i was
recently very unwell um and therefore
that exact guidance i found i had
covered so it is still worth doing for
all the time being
and then post the end of march we're
still again awaiting what the specific
national guidance is going to be but we
believe the advice will be basically to
stay at home if you're ill and after the
31st of march until you get better and
obviously you're still able to go and
buy like a flow test if you're really
concerned i do think that will be a
really key message going forward whether
or not it's covered or not if you're
feeling unwell um stay at home um don't
go out and about i think that's that's
going to be really crucial to push
forward over the coming weeks or so and
that's everything from me on on testing
any
questions thank you are there any
questions at all for ben
i i don't see any ben can i thank you
for your work in this area it's been
it's been lots of information coming
forward
every time we've met thank you
um so shall we move on then to uh
outbreak management contact tracing
with with kirsty johnson kirsty with
contact tracing ending perhaps you could
tell us how we're going to continue to
support schools and businesses for the
next 12 months
thank you sure no worries thank you
and so as helen mentioned uh
we've got the living with coal with plan
in place now which outlines the measures
on lifting restrictions
so although there's no legal duty to
self-isolate you know we're still pretty
much expecting staff members and
children within schools to stay at home
and avoid close contact with other
people so still staying at home for five
days
at least five days taking two lfd tests
after five days and if both are negative
they can return to school
um
and as long as they feel well and they
don't have a temperature
so in line with the living with covered
plan the education contingency framework
has changed slightly so those outbreak
thresholds
were pretty clear before so we could
look at it as five cases in a class when
somebody was meeting an outbreak
that's changed now and it's it's shifted
to a higher than previously
or rapidly increasing number of cases
so it's a little bit loose in in the
terms of what can trigger an outbreak
in scn settings so in our specialist
education settings and settings where
there's um very small classes of less
than 20 people
um an outbreak will be triggered with
two or more link cases so there's lower
thresholds for those those vulnerable
settings
and we are seeing a lot of increased
activity across schools in line with the
covered rates across the community at
the minute so we have four primary
schools three special schools and one
secondary school
and that are currently meeting those
eight break thresholds
and we are seeing it you know it we're
going from
zero to ten cases in a classroom in a
very short period of time
so corvid still is very much um
the in our schools um and across the
borough
so the the outbreaks will be still
continuing to support schools without
breaking the outbreak hub supporting
skills in managing them
and we can recommend
additional measures in line with the
contingency framework
so
schools should be sticking to them then
key measures of good hygiene really
making sure that the washing hands
regular
maintaining appropriate cleaning regimes
and good ventilation so letting that
earth flow through school
and and i think we've mentioned a couple
of times about if somebody has got
symptoms to go for that pcr test
so although the guidances do test with
the three main symptoms what we are
seeing amongst children is a lot of um
vomiting
and
sore bodies
achy bones and really high temperatures
so i think if in doubt um whether it's a
fever in a high temperature or there's
something not quite right just go for
that pcr test
there are other measures so we can
reintroduce additional testing and face
coverings in school
um in an outbreak situation and that's
in line with agreement from the director
of public health and that is in the
contingency framework that you know we
can do that across schools
and in terms of
routine testing so routine testing as we
know is no longer advised in secondary
schools
and close contacts don't need to daily
test anymore but again in an outbreak
situation we might recommend some
additional testing
workplaces they're no longer to require
to report call big cases to us and so
that means there's minimal
surveillance and reporting of cases and
because there's you know that they no
longer need to contact trace in the
national system so that's just something
that we need to keep an eye on in terms
of monitoring what it looks like across
our workplaces
so workplaces are expected to follow the
working safely with call with guidance
um but again we're still here to support
any business settings or workplaces if
they do have an outbreak
and we have a number of care settings
with with corvic cases which the initial
will talk about shortly
um and then finally the contact tracing
so as we know routine contact racing um
finished on the 24th of march
so
um contacts are no longer you know the
the that legal requirement to isolate
and then there's no contact racing
taking place from the national service
and so the national system which is
called ctas that's been completely
switched off now
um so we no longer have access to that
and test and trace support payments they
ended from the 24th of february
and but anybody who tested positive
before that they still have 42 days to
claim that testing trade support payment
which takes us up to the 23rd of april
so if anybody tested positive before the
24th of february they still have 42 days
to claim
um the national team are reviewing the
kovic capability across local
authorities if we do need to step things
back up so that's a piece of work that's
been undertaken
and and obviously as a local authority
we're developing processes and systems
if we do need to step things back up
quickly
um all our businesses and schools know
that we're here to support them in an
outbreak situation and we just continue
to offer advice and guidance to them
thank you thank you kirsty that's very
reassuring and and i think
as a school chair of governors i know
how good the the the outbreak
management's been with schools and and
you know and the schools of my school
where it's happened it has been really
really impressed so thank you very very
much indeed are there any questions at
all uh for kirsty
i don't see any kirstie can i thank you
for your contributions to these meetings
it's been very very informative thank
you
uh can i therefore invite benice to talk
to us about uh care outbreaks and care
homes and assisted living denise welcome
thank you good morning chair
over the past week we have been seeing
increased activity across our care homes
and supported accommodation settings
we have
three settings uh on our watch list at
the moment and eight settings with an
outbreak and we have managed to close
around 16 outbreaks since january
we have we continue to work very closely
with our settings um together
information on any cases that are
identified
see if there's any ongoing transmission
within our settings and we're working in
partnership to bring
any transmission that's been identified
to an end by offering recommendations
support and addressing any queries or
concerns the settings may have
our data capture system is working
incredibly well
and we are responding even more promptly
um and efficiently to um any issues or
support requests from our care homes
and supported accommodation settings uh
we've also been to virtual meetings with
our care homes and supported living
settings to answer any frequently asked
questions or
concerns
around the guidelines as they stand
at present there's been an update to
admission and care of residents in a
care home during covert 19 guideline
that to reflect the removal um
of the legal requirement for people with
covet 19 to self isolate in line with
the government's approach to living with
covet
so due to the higher risk nature of the
health and social care settings
the advice for our the residents and
staff members working in these settings
has not changed
and um
i'd like to take this opportunity to um
of course you know echo helens and my
colleagues comments and you know thank
our adult and social care settings our
work is every every member of the board
our partners and our residents uh
everyone and you know it's been it's
been incredibly difficult but you know
we've all worked in partnership work
together to keep everyone safe so thank
you all and thank you to the counselor
chair thank you everybody
thank you venetian of course we'll
continue to work with them as well and
as we go forward um are there any
questions at all for bernice at all
i i don't see any thank you again
vanessa the inputs you've made to these
meetings as well uh can we move on then
to mass vaccination mark welcome
thank you um so
i i think it's a thank you
to everybody again um trafford has been
very successful in its vaccination
program up to this point i think we are
the best performing
locality within greater manchester
um
in what we've achieved and we've
achieved approximately eight percent of
those eligible have had at least two
doses and of those who are eligible for
a booster
uh approximately 85 have had their
booster so the people who want to get
vaccinated
do get vaccinated and have taken it up
well um and we've done lots of work
to try and
encourage those who are less
enthusiastic
to take up the vaccine as well and we've
had great success in in getting to those
groups
and compared to all the other areas so
we've done
well so far we are still
continuing to vaccinate anybody who
comes along
the contracts for vaccination were due
to end at the end of march
but have been adjusted slightly
for the uh for the change of numbers
that are likely to come through but
have now been extended to the end of
september
because there is going to be
um a spring
booster for the immuno compromised
and
there is a national program for to offer
to five to eleven healthy five to eleven
year olds the detail of which has not
yet come out but but we have it it seems
likely that that will be through the
national booking system
um
and we have ensured that the providers
within trafford the pharmacy providers
within trafford who are on that national
booking system do have the training and
capacity to be able to deliver that to
that age group so
we've done well we've still got
provision in place
we're planning for the
um next sets of vaccination that we are
knowing we know are coming and we know
we've got the capacity in place to
continue to do that
um we're gonna have to wait and see what
comes in the autumn
the details then
um are a little bit too far ahead for me
to be able to um
to go into but
at the moment i believe it we've got it
covered and we're continuing to work
with everybody to ensure that
we continue that high level of
performance we've achieved so far
i think that's it for me but i'll do my
best to answer any questions thank you
mark i think we'd also would also like
to say a big thank you to the trafford
residents that have come forward um
absolutely but can i pass on my thanks
to all of the ccg primary care
our pharmacies that have all stood up
all the temporary sites we've done
everything else and the volunteers that
were involved in that as well a big
thanks to all them for the work that was
done i have a question from councillor
blackburn
thank you mark could i ask you in the
future is it likely that when people
have the flu jab there will be a sort of
a kobe jab um included with it
um
it's
i think it's going to be two separate
jabs i've not read anything that
suggests that we won't combine
vaccination at this point in time
but this year we we had the opportunity
to do
both jobs on the same day you could go
to the clinic and have your covered in
one arm and a flu in the other arm
that was within the
regulations and it would be sensible
um from a
a resource point of view if we could
arrange to do that in the future
the the regulations and the timing of
deliveries
of the flu jab and the kovid jabs didn't
match so that wasn't always possible
um for the booster program
um however you know going forward that
would be
the most effective way for us to deliver
it as long as we
can get the supplies it's more the
logistics under the limiters on that
um than the theory
and the willingness
um so
but it is possible
and it would be preferable
um
but that doesn't mean i can guarantee it
okay thank you mark
can i just ask mark on the flu jab did i
read somewhere that flu jabs were no
longer going to be free uh next time out
um
the
there's a question about which groups it
would be free to
in the autumn season
um so
they they extended flu jabs to the over
50s um at the start of the panda and it
might have been the winter before and
there is some question about which
groups will be eligible for the free flu
vaccination it's not
um so the the higher risk groups um i'm
sure still will be
um
the question is more about the
50 to 65s with
no underlying health problems who've
been eligible for free jobs for this
for the last two or three years who may
or may not
in this autumn's campaign um and it's a
proposal rather than a decision at this
point in time as i understand it
thank you that's cleared up that then um
we'll have to obviously await the
guidance as we do on everything are
there any further questions for mark
thank you again mark for your attendance
at the meeting and also keep us on my
thanks to rebecca who did it before you
uh and uh i'm very grateful for the
input we've had from you um
can i pass on then to community
engagement and uh
julia burgess allen jilla welcome
you yes the community engagement team
are busy out in the community this
morning um but danny has
provided an update which um i can
pass on to you all
so they've been doing some school visits
and
that's been linked to the 12 to 15
vaccination program
but it's not solely a focus on
vaccination it's also
looking at those neighborhoods where we
have seen quite high rates
in school-aged children and going in and
doing some sessions
in person around hand hygiene
and safe covered behaviours and those
have been going down really well
and
also a new programme started which
aims to support people experiencing the
economic impact of covid and that is
called cooking with seoul and it's
um learning to cook on a budget
and
preparing meals with ingredients from
scratch and doing that in an affordable
way and
those are in person but you can also
join from your kitchen via zoom and cook
along
with the facilitator and we had 30 women
attend the first session in old trafford
so that was a really good turnout very
positive
um otherwise still working with the
volunteers um and uh also it's worth
saying that as we um move into uh this
next period spring and summer we will be
increasingly supporting the community
engagement team um around curbid
recovery
rather than covert response
and that cooking with seoul project is
an example of that so it's
working with communities
to address some of those wider impacts
that covert has had
thank you
thank you chiller any questions for
jailor at all
i don't see any um
which really brings us is that any other
business anyone wants to raise at all
today
uh no i don't see any other so it's
really brings us to the conclusion and
can i just say as chair pass on the
thanks i have to all the public health
teams
everybody
across
the ccg
and all the volunteers or everybody
that's that's that's really contributed
to getting the message out and also a
thank you to our stakeholders who attend
this meeting um that have come week
every fortnight and have taken the
message back to their own communities
for us and finally i'd also like to
thank committee services for supporting
this meeting uh but you know molly and
alex week in week out and be um because
you know without them we couldn't have
run this meeting and
i'd say it's been i'd just like to say a
big big thank you to everybody that's
been involved i think with the trafford
response has been absolutely fantastic i
know that the leader of the council has
been delighted with the way this this
meeting has run um and uh it's been an
absolute pleasure to share it so thank
you all and and hopefully we won't have
to reconvene but it's reassuring to know
that we have in place the the means to
do that uh if it if so required so thank
you very much indeed
have a very good day
thank you